racism is a huge problem in our world we
need the whales free of racism
i hope from now on every month is black
history month
sometimes the smallest voices pack the
biggest punch
martin luther king inspired our speeches
because his speech was to stop
just one thing in the world he's just
really inspiring so
everyone's just getting together just to
stop this racism
these pupils are from one of cardiff's
most diverse schools
would you like to tell us about some of
the things that you've been learning
lafayette
we've been learning about platforms mata
and
how to stop racism and how to be
anti-racist
you've been learning blocks black
history here isn't one lesson
it's part of everything they learn our
children need to see themselves
reflected in the curriculum
we look at our local history the coal
industry world war one world war ii
how is it that cardiff bay is so diverse
so through all of that they have a sense
of belonging
but head to the welsh valleys and
there's a very different landscape
here ethnic diversity is low
but it's a large part of kojo hazel's
lessons
george floyd hands up if you heard that
name it's
my job really certainly as a role model
for these peoples here
and to be able to teach them about
what's outside the valleys you know
what's what's in the wider world and
give them a real rounded experience so
they can when they do eventually get to
leave they've got you know much more
better understanding
and for this pe lesson that
understandings all about
black athletes okay bottom right hand
corner
muhammad ali i enjoyed it
i felt like it brought a new insight to
what is going on
i didn't know who like 80
of the people were we're in charge of
making the world a nicer place in the
future so
i think it's important to the people of
the
older generations and show us how to
make the world a better place
black history will be mandatory in the
new welsh curriculum
none of the other nations have gone this
far
this is just as important to the maths
teacher
as it is to the musical history teacher
professor charlotte williams helped
develop the new curriculum
this is the right of every child in
wales
to have their knowledge base enriched
and expanded and to be
prepared for the global connectedness
of wales the diversity of
wales is woven into its history and very
soon
these stories will be told in every
school
laura bundock sky news cardiff